at the start of the movie Jillian
armacost watches out her window as a
shuttle takes off she is a second grade
teacher at a junior high suddenly one of
her students informs her that there is a
phone call for her Jillian takes the
call which turns out to be from the NASA
communications center the phone is then
connected to her husband Spencer
armacost who is an astronaut working for
NASA the call seems inappropriate for
Jillian as her husband should be
orbiting the Earth right now regardless
she happily chats with him later at home
she talks about this with her sister Nan
the latter thinks Jillian is very lucky
to have a husband like Spencer suddenly
the TV starts showing breaking news
covering the recent accident at one of
NASA's outer space stations the incident
included her husband and another NASA
Captain named Alex Strack at the same
time the doorbell rings and when Jillian
answers it a man named Sherman Reese
introduces himself and says that he is
from NASA prior to explaining everything
to her Sherman asks Jillian to go with
him in the next scene Jillian is taken
to the NASA headquarters orders where
she meets Natalie Alex streck's wife the
devastated women Embrace each other
believing that their husbands are dead
however the NASA director arrives and
gives them the good news their husbands
are safe and Alive the bad news is
they're getting plowed by aliens right
now I'm just kidding
it is then revealed that Spencer and
Alex were working in outer space
repairing a satellite when suddenly
there was an explosion due to this the
NASA communications center lost contact
with them for a while the director
informs the wives that their husbands
have boarded a shuttle and are now
returning to Earth Sherman then Taps on
a broadcast camera enabling the women to
see their husbands from Earth a few
hours later Alex and Spencer Land safely
but are taken to the hospital due to
injuries from the explosion the doctor
assures Jillian that her husband will be
all right however Alex has sustained
major injuries so he has to be kept in
the Intensive Care Unit as the days pass
Jillian spends her time sitting beside
her husband's bed while he is recovering
eventually Spencer wakes up relieving
Jillian from her worries however Alex's
condition continues to deteriorate in
one instance he suffers from a medical
emergency because of which he requires
electrical cardioversion when Alex
starts acting violently the doctors have
to resuscitate him Natalie tearfully
watches her husband from the sidelines
unable to help him at all but thankfully
after of excruciating waiting the
doctors managed to save Alex and put him
on medication soon after the astronauts
are praised for their heroic Deeds while
at a celebration party Natalie shares
her concern with Jillian after her
husband recovered he hasn't uttered a
word about the accident but it turns out
not only Alex but Spencer has also been
rather quiet nonetheless the two women
conclude that their husbands simply need
some time to recover from The Nightmare
after the party Spencer tells his wife
that he has decided to leave the service
and he's accepted a position with a new
york-based company McLaren Jillian isn't
happy about leaving the city as she has
become accustomed to it but she doesn't
have much of a choice the following day
while the couple is attending another
event they notice Alex's aggressive
behavior towards his wife he is arguing
with her over something at a nearby
table suddenly Alex starts bleeding from
his mouth and drops to the floor Spencer
hurries to check on his colleague but
it's too late Alex is pronounced dead on
the scene devastating everyone around
soon after a press conference South
where the NASA Representatives attribute
Alex's death to a stroke during the
funeral Chilean approaches Natalie in
private to comfort her Natalie shares
that lately it felt like her husband was
talking to somebody not of our world she
also feels like someone is living inside
of her Jillian Comforts her thinking
it's the trauma that caused Alex's death
she then joins Spencer leaving Natalie
alone in the room a few minutes later
they suddenly hear a scream everyone
rushes to Natalie's room only to find
her dad in the bathtub it turns out that
she committed the unthinkable unable to
Bear the pain of her husband's loss
anymore sometime after Jillian and
Spencer moved to New York at a work
party she notices her husband acting
differently he was never a social person
but now he has many Elite circles
Jillian asks him to tell her about the
spacewalk incident and what happened
during the two minutes when their
connection with NASA was shut however
when he starts answering the next thing
Jillian knows she is in bed with him
everything seems like a dream to her and
she can only hear Spencer's voice in the
the background later when she wakes up
Jillian feels a sharp pain in her
stomach she also hears strange noises
inside her head something which she has
never experienced before in the next
scene Jillian continues to be
overwhelmed by what she experienced the
other night she calls her sister Nan and
informs her that she cannot live in such
a huge city as New York and that things
have been very weird lately soon
afterward Jillian finds out that she is
pregnant with twins but for some reason
she feels no joy two heads are not
better than one when they're emerging
from your crotch one evening Spencer
takes Jillian to have dinner at his boss
Mr McLaren's place the latter is a very
sophisticated and materialistic person
something which Jillian dislikes when he
and his wife go away to put their
daughter to sleep Spencer asks Jillian
what has been going on with her lately
Jillian tells him that she doesn't
belong to his newly found Elite circles
and neither does he she reminds him that
he had once told her he would never give
up his career as an astronaut but after
the accident in space Spencer is changed
then with a nervous tone Jillian reveals
that she is pregnant much to the Delight
of Spencer the following day the couple
goes to the doctor to examine the
pregnancy when she and the doctor are
alone Jillian shares that earlier in her
life after her parents died she sought
psychiatric care because she started to
see her loved ones dead including
herself she also tells the doctor that
recently she has been having nightmares
which she fears might affect the
pregnancy hearing all this the doctor
advises Jillian to give her a call if an
emergency comes up after the meeting
Jillian decides to join a support group
of mothers who are expecting twins this
turns out to be a great idea as she
finally gets the motivation and help she
was looking for cut to a few months
later Jillian appears to be very
comfortable with her pregnancy she and
her husband are now happily looking
forward to the birth of their babies one
day when Jillian visits the baby store
she is suddenly approached by Sherman
Reese who looks worried he says that he
wants to talk about the two minutes when
her husband didn't have a connection
with the NASA communications center he
also asks Jillian if she is known
noticed Spencer acting differently ever
since the accident it is revealed that
Sherman has been terminated from NASA
because after his investigation he had
insisted to the authorities that
something was wrong with Spencer though
all the tests came back normal he shows
Jillian some official papers and proves
that Spencer's signature is different
ever since his return from space
additionally his medical indicators have
also changed however Jillian thinks
Sherman is crazy and her hunch is
further confirmed when she learns that
he was fired by NASA she asks him not to
pursue her but Sherman is persistent
when he reveals that Natalie was
pregnant at the time of her death
Jillian is taken aback Sherman is fully
convinced that something more than just
an explosion happened while the two
astronauts were orbiting Earth he then
gives Jillian a tape recorder which
contains the entire conversation between
the astronauts while they were in space
later Jillian listens to the tape and
shockingly learns that Alex and Spencer
saw something during those two minutes
something which they had never seen or
heard of in their entire lives suddenly
there is a knock on the door and Jillian
nervously goes to open it to her relief
it's just not who has come all the way
to New York to surprise her sister as
the two chat Jillian explains everything
that has been happening in her life as
of late she also talks about her recent
findings on Spencer but warns her sister
did not tell anybody about it one
evening Jillian gets a call from Sherman
and shockingly learns that Natalie was
also pregnant with twins she frantically
asks what the autopsy showed about the
Twins and Sherman responds that he needs
to meet her in person to show her the
following morning the two meet near the
subway but just as they are about to
discuss Natalie's autopsy Spencer shows
up Jillian quickly hides herself and the
two men start chatting about their time
in NASA when the conversation drags for
too long Jillian runs away from the
scene later she tries to reach Sherman
by calling the hotel where he is
currently staying but to no avail
thankfully as a backup plan Sherman has
sent Jillian a key to a vault there is
also a note addressed to her which
points her to a location upon reaching
into Jillian discovers photographs of
her husband and learns that Sherman had
been keeping an eye on him since his
return from the space mission she also
finds a VHS video cassette but when she
tries to play it the light suddenly goes
out Jillian panics and runs away from
the Vault by now she is certain that
something evil is after her later at
home she watches the video where Sherman
demonstrates what really happened in
space he explains that there was a
mysterious signal near Spencer and Alex
when they lost contact with NASA Sherman
believes the signal was an alien that
wanted to get to Earth so they took over
the astronaut's body however Alex's
vitals didn't sustain the alien's Mass
causing his death Jillian relates the
video to her husband's recent erratic
behavior and how she has been facing
nightmares about her own death she also
recognizes the signal which sounds
exactly like the one she had heard
during the work party in New York when
she was somewhat unconscious after
seeing the video Jillian is convinced
that her husband is not who he says he
is he is an alien and there is a high
possibility that her unborn twins are
also from out of this world following
this realization Jillian attempts a
medical abortion but is soon caught by
Spencer in the ACT he then slaps her
warning her to not do anything like this
in the future in response Jillian throws
herself down a flight of stairs and
wakes up in the hospital Spencer reveals
that the twins survived the fall but
warns her to keep silent about what had
happened while recovering Jillian sees a
dream where her sister Nan is killed by
Spencer freaked out she leaves the
hospital on her own but Spencer follows
her because of his weird connection with
the alien twins inside of her she
arrives home quickly barricades the door
and goes into the room where she dreamed
her sister was killed Jillian then sees
her body on the floor but then it is
gone probably because it was a vision
when Spencer breaks his way into the
apartment she has flooded the kitchen
floor with water with a radio in the
sink and an extension cord plugged into
the wall Jillian holds the ends of the
cords in each hand and tells Spencer to
stay away from her she then notices
bloody nail marks on his hand and
realizes that her sister really is dead
just as she had dreamed in the final
confrontation Jillian tells Spencer that
she knows who he is and that he killed
her sister hearing this the alien inside
Spencer's body finally speaks up and
says
and says that he did Kill non because
she was getting in his way now he lives
inside of Jillian through his link with
the twins just then water begins pouring
down from the ceiling and at the perfect
time Jillian lifts her feet off the wet
floor and connects the court this sends
a deadly wave of current towards Spencer
killing him once and for all however the
alien inside of his body comes out and
transmits into Jillian several years
after the incident we learned that
Jillian has remarried and her twin sons
are living a completely normal life her
current husband also turns out to be an
astronaut just like Spencer once was the
movie ends as Jillian proudly watches
her son's board the school bus she is
sure that they will also end up like
their father failures
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching